the overall restaurant industry Nigel
has seen a slowdown in the past six to
nine months what evidence do you see out
there of that tapering off now well I
think firstly scarlet good afternoon and
yeah I think we've seen plenty of
evidence in all the different segments
of the restaurant industry fast casual
casual dining q sr I think we're helped
a little bit that we're in the
fastest-growing part of the restaurant
industry which is the breakfast a part
and an even faster segment is coffee
everyone wants to get into coffee so
it's competitive its its fast-growing I
think the economy is clearly steadily
improving we'd love to see GDP above
three percent so far it hasn't got there
but I think the recent jobs report
showed that everything's going in the
right direction so I'm hoping that this
year the restaurant industry will
probably have some struggles but I think
it will steadily come out of this trough
that we've seen for the last period of
time as you said and of course with
Duncan focusing so much on beverages we
see coffee prices rising a bit as well
what does this mean for your franchisees
or their planned price increases in 2017
especially as you look at the political
environment and all to talk about import
taxes on potential your beans from
Central and South America
well we've essentially built out for
most of the year on coffee
we actually don't see too much inflation
on coffee beans this year I think that
our franchise de onde DCP has done a
very nice job on that obviously the
import tax is something that's tough to
take into account because there seems to
be all kinds of debate about it but
we're looking to the future with some
confidence on commodities I think
commodities overall this year are
essentially flat to actually be in a
tailwind which is not something I would
have said to you two months ago I think
it's actually improved in the last
couple of months so we feel good about
that and on pricing
Duncan is about valued our franchisees
understand that we've worked with them
very hard on pricing or what we call
smart pricing and yeah a couple of years
ago they may have gone too far on
increasing prices at restaurant level I
think they've actually they actually now
understand that that's not helpful to
driving
traffic back to your earlier question
and I think we're in for a good period
of time where we're not gonna see too
many price increases and that's going to
be good for our consumers and good for
our traffic nigel scarlett mentioned the
political situation and of course the
other thing that's happening in
corporate news and politics is
essentially the politicization of all
brands we saw during the superbowl we
see Trump calling out President Trump
calling out companies from time to time
it seems like despite the best efforts
of corporations they get sucked into
being on one side or the other how are
you thinking about that risk as a very
prominent consumer brand with a lot of
brand identity this risk that's out
there of your brands at some point
theoretically becoming politicized in
some way so Joe interesting question and
thank you for that I mean one of the
things I've tried to represent through
my time at Dunkin which is just about
eight years now is if we want to grow we
have to do it through our franchisees
and whenever we think about how we
influence administrations whatever
persuasion they are we have to do it
through their eyes so we try and stay
out of too much controversy we try and
make sure that our point is made we talk
to the administration we talk to States
we talk to cities all the time we take
groups of franchisees with us and and
basically our message is we need
policies that's good for small business
our franchisees are small businesspeople
we need policies for instance the tax
reform will be very helpful for all of
us and obviously sensible tax reform
immigration reform because one of the
things that our franchisees are
challenged with day-in day-out and they
complain all the time is fine in labor I
mean there is a little bit of a labor
shortage now which seems perverse after
some of the struggles over the last few
years we need some hold up on regulation
I mean I'll give you an example we had a
store that was being built in the
Midwest it was held up for over two
years because two water authorities were
arguing over who had jurisdiction over
that particular piece of land so I think
it's a lot of things we need
we try and be very practical we need to
be very we try and be straightforward we
try to be very civil you know we spend a
lot of time talking to administrators
right around the country so I think by
having good solid and sensible messages
that they understand we get our point
across well to that point that I wonder
what kind of impact have you already
seen on the president's immigration ban
how is it affecting your decision-making
right now at the moment
well Scarlett's good question we
actually checked on that we've actually
had none of our franchisees tell us
about any impact so far I I just think
that it's probably too early but we've
not heard anything from our franchisees
on it I want you to look back to a macro
question you mentioned the theoretical
the possible labor shortage out there
what is the situation in terms of wages
and how that's affecting franchise
emergence well well clearly there's been
some very fast moves to $15 in certain
states like California and New York a
franchisees have been concerned about
that but I don't want to give the
impression that they're anti the minimum
wage going up in fact we've always
encouraged very positive discussions
about that and we actually do believe
that increase in the minimum wage has
some kind of accelerating effect on the
economy but franchisees have been
concerned so we've worked with them as
many things we can do internally we've
looked at things like energy we look to
using labor more efficiently we've
introduced technology like our on-the-go
app is designed to actually reduce the
amount of discussion time between the
guest and the crew member we're looking
at streamlining our menu through a major
test we announced today but we'd also we
also think there's opportunities out
there sensible immigration return reform
is one as is trying to find ways to
recruit more younger workers because
youth unemployment is still above ten
percent and of course staying with the
macro idea you're expanding in China and
your big supporter of global free trade
despite what the president has said
you've said that you would give the
president concrete examples of the
benefits of being a free trade supporter
what is your most compelling
argument and have you made it to the
administration well we've not actually
sat down with the administration as yet
but I'm sure we will do we we had very
good discussions with the last two or
three administration so we'll find an
opportunity to do that yeah we do
support free trade we were in 61
countries I was in China Korea and Japan
three weeks ago they're all talking
about TPP they're actually talking about
taking advantage of the fact that
America is dropping out of that so it is
important to try and hopefully get rid
of some of these barriers so that we can
move products around the world
we actually have examples on the ice
cream side of our business the
baskin-robbins side where the more
countries we can get into will be good
for jobs in America because our ice
cream there is exported around the world
is actually made in Alabama so you know
we look forward to good positive
discussions about trade and obviously
trade isn't just focused on the US
there's some moves in Europe like brexit
in my original home country that we're
concerned about as well and we've made
our point on that very strongly not only
to the foreign secretary but also the
British ambassador because we believe
that access to the broader market the EU
market is very important
Nigel final question to you in December
you struck your first national sports
partnership with the National Hockey
League being a big hockey fan I was of
course I love that news I wonder what
other kind of partnerships you're
looking into now well we we've had lots
of partnerships with different sports
teams over the years Scarlett and I
didn't know you were a hockey fan but we
saw that it's a great opportunity we saw
that for two or three reasons amazingly
and you've proven the point a lot of
women love hockey so we saw that as a
way of accessing a very good very strong
segment of our customer base secondly
we've had huge success with affiliations
with teams where if they win you get a
special price coffee something like that
I mean up here when the New England
Patriots won the other night in a very
exciting game we gave away 87 cent
coffee
we will do the same with hockey teams
and and the great hook for us is to
drive people into our perks program that
we believe is great value of consumers
but most of all gets them very quickly
onto on-the-go ordering which helps
speed up our transactions and gives us a
lot of data for one-to-one marketing so
we think that deal with the NHL is great
it's going to be great for dunking going
forward and we look forward to many
relationships with the National Hockey
League teams